à l'évidence
ce une un dysfonctionnement majeur a eu
lieu
nous sommes permis de projeter quelques
images qui viennent de collègues de
terrain pour démontrer ce qu'il s'est
passé
en tous les cas à créditer les propos
qui ont été tenus par exemple en haute
savoie avec l'expédition dans veloppe
brûler des enveloppes éparpillés sur les
routes de leurs des cartons d' enveloppe
non distribués dans l'ain et dans
d'autres départements où ces constats
ont pu être également partager ce ne
sont que des exemples
naturellement cette situation n'exonère
pas l'organisation générale et voilà les
images que vous pouvez voir en haute
savoie dans leur également dans le
département de l'ain
l'organisation des élections dépend bien
sûr du goût de l'exécutif certains
mettent en cause les condition dans
laquelle le marché public a été conclue
en remettant en cause le sérieux de
celui ci certains routeurs n'ont pas été
capables de mener à bien cette mission
dans une période j'allais dire de
prendre près premier tour c'est à dire
sans pression d'urgence majeure avec un
peu de temps nous sommes à partir
d'aujourd'hui engagé dans la préparation
du deuxième tour les distributions
devraient arriver dans les jours qui
viennent dans les heures qui viennent
on prend nos concitoyens nous avons
évidemment des inquiétudes est ce la
raison pour laquelle monsieur le
ministre nous vous demandons de savoir à
la suite des rendez vous que vous avez
eue
quelles mesures seront mises en place en
prévision de ce deuxième tour l'exercice
du droit de vote
c'est l'aboutissement le plus concret du
système démocratique la sécurité de
celui ci les conditions dans lesquelles
la propagande électorale c'est à dire en
réalité les professions de foi de tous
les candidats arrivent dans les boîtes
aux lettres de nos concitoyens sont le
gage de cette démocratie respecter
abouti sécurisé ce matin nous vous
demandons de nous donner des
explications en tous les cas à ce stade
celle que vous pouvez nous donner on
organisera une série de questions nous
savons vous avez le conseil des
ministres qui suit une autre audition
je demanderai aux collègues de respecter
vraiment un délai de deux minutes
maximum pour intervenir
nous attendons beaucoup de vous ce matin
dans les explications de ce
fonctionnement ou ce dysfonctionnement
directement que certains qualifient donc
dès aujourd'hui des fiascos
merci de votre attention de sony vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président messieurs les sénateurs
est ce qu'il ya eu dysfonctionnement
dans la distribution d'après pagnol la
réponse est évidemment oui
est ce que c'est la seule raison de
l'abstention très importante que nous
avons vu
au moins de juin dernier la réponse est
à mon avis pas totalement oui si vous me
le permettez je constate d'ailleurs que
les pays qui ont mis en place le débat
s'ouvre indépendamment la propagande
dont je répondrais évidemment devant
votre commission j'ai toujours eu
l'habitude de répondre aux convocations
des commissions monsieur président deby
commis en place par exemple votre par
correspondance n'ont pas obtenu à ma
connaissance d'efficacité plus grand
dans les taux de participation en
angleterre en 2021 pour l'élection des
maires centre 29 et 40 % de
participation alors que le vote postal
par exemple est un vote qui est
culturellement mis en avant mais il est
évident que dans les opérations
électorales la connaissance des propres
les documents de propagande comme on les
appelle dans le code électoral sont
importants et permettent égalité entre
les candidats il faut distinguer deux
types d'opérations la mise sous pli où
on doit avoir l'ensemble des documents
qui doivent être dans cette distribution
et puis la distribution soit la mise
sous pli la plupart des préfectures
encore sont en régie et grâce à des
vacataires souvent de l'emprunt public
chaque année connaît parfois aller
visiter l avec des élections mais est
arrivé plus d'une seule fois y compris
d'ailleurs avec les agents des communes
cette mise sous pli s'est fait dans des
conditions que l'on pourrait qualifier
de normal même s'il peut y avoir ici ou
là une documents trop récente qui
manquent de tel ou tel candidat ça nous
est arrivé je crois et dans des
élections précédentes même si nous
constatons que par le moment c'est le
manque d'agents de service public
puisque je rappelle que depuis quinze
ans les sous préfectures et préfectures
ont perdu énormément de leur emploi et
que pour la première fois de l'année
dernière l'emploi des préfectures
restriction n'a pas baissé notre pays la
lozère est passé par an 230 agents à 90
si je prends cet exemple précis nous
avons nous sommes passés ministre de
l'intérieur parfois par des sous
traitants qui ont pu permettre de mettre
en place la mise sous pli mais le sujet
principal c'est la distribution de la
propagande distribution la propagande
qui rend du complexe pour trois raisons
qui sont extérieurs et une réseau qui
est propre à ces élections
première raison qui est extérieur c'est
évidemment les plis non distribués qui
relève notamment des listes électorales
qui peuvent parfois être mal tenu et
notamment dans les points les plus
urbains 13 % par exemple de non
distribution en seine-saint-denis contre
3 % en lozère que la mobilité des
électeurs et participer la difficulté
d'accéder à certains de l'immeuble
deuxième sujet c'est évidemment la
concomitance de ces deux élections dont
je rappelle que depuis 1986 on a eu ce
débat longuement la france n'avait pas
organisé sur son sol deux élections en
même temps sur tout le territoire
national à l'exception alpes 1986 si
puisqu'on gerald c'était soit cantonales
à moitié et régionales soient
municipales à moitié cantonales
s'étaient toutes les départementales et
toutes les régionales à l'exception de
la métropole lyonnaise et de la ville de
paris sur des sujets qui peuvent
intéresser état étant ultra marins donc
elle est un défi logistique était
important qui a été souligné qu'ils
étaient notamment souligné par un
rapport sénatorial y compris des
inquiétudes de la profession puisque le
sénateur qu'a pu et je ne vais pas vous
rappeler le texte de sa proposition de
modernisation et de simplification et du
rapport qu'elle avait mis avait évoqué
déjà en auditionnant ce qui était
titulaire du marché leur difficulté de
tenir ces élections surtout dans une
période pandémique dont chacun se
rappelle sans doute de la discussion que
nous avons eue pour savoir s'il fallait
maintenir ou pas ces élections
et puis troisièmement il ya eu à un
régime de libéralisation de la
distribution de la propagande jusque
dans les années 2000 c'était les agents
de l'état en lien direct avec la poste
qui organisait la distribution de la
propagande électorale sous le
gouvernement de lionel jospin il ya eu
deux directives ont été adoptées par le
conseil européen
celle de 97 décès de 2002 qui prévoit
l'ouverture à la concurrence du domaine
postal est dans l'ouverture à la
concurrence de même postale
il ya la propagande électorale c'est
clairement inscrit dans la directive
négocié par le gouvernement d'alors en
2005 par une loi de régulation postale
la diffusion de propagande électorale
est prévue par appel d'offres le premier
appel d'offres date de 2009
le deuxième appel d'offres pour la cette
séquence 2013 2016
le troisième après appel d'offres pour
2017 2020 l'arcep
qui est l'autorité qui régularise et qui
jeudi donnent le blanc seing pour
accepter de concurrence et à certain
nombre d'opérateurs qui avait
manifestement le monopole comme la poste
a accordé la société avec soin la
possibilité de concurrencer la poste et
c'est ainsi que conformément à la loi de
régulation aux directives européennes et
aux marchés publics la société adrexo a
obtenu une partie du marché pour un
montant total mais je m'échine que
pourrait demander c'est de toujours
sauter d'à peu près 200 millions d'euros
on s'est réparti les régions avec des
distributions de propagande d'une part
pour la poste d'autres parcours avec
saut dans la distribution de la
propagande
les difficultés ont été constatées de
deux manières la première c'était des
envois très tôt dans la campagne pour un
certain nombre de candidats et même
lorsqu'il ya eu des élections
législatives partielles parfois des
candidats ont reçu des professions de
foi ou des bulletins de vote des
élections départementales avant que la
législative partielle du début juin
n'ait lieu qui a pu entraîner quelques
confusions
évidemment pour les électeurs et de
manière générale des envois notamment
pour les départementales bien en amont
parfois trois semaines avant le premier
tour des élections régionales
si ce cas était déplorable moi je les
personnes ont regretté nous l'avons déjà
fait remonter secrétariat le ministère
et est à mes côtés pourraient en
témoigner si vous le souhaitez dans
votre commission ce que je constate que
le législateur et le le pouvoir exécutif
d'alors qui avait rédigé code électoral
n'a pas mis de bornes dans la
distribution de la propagande donc c'est
un bon compte malheureusement et
peut-être qu'il faudrait réfléchir pour
l'avenir que les documents j'en ai parlé
à être présentes bussereau qui m'avait
interpellé à l'époque sur ce point et
quelques élus ont reçu parfois beaucoup
trop tôt et qui a peut être contribué
sans doute à discussion des documents
mais ceux constatés j'ai découvert qu'il
n'y avait pas de bornes de distribution
de propagande électorale sans doute et
une modification apportée dans les
prochains textes législatifs est ce que
tu es de nature législative
en revanche dans la distribution du
document nous avons constaté de sérieux
manquements ont marché que nous avons
constaté de la société adrexo même si
contrairement à ce que j'ai pu entendre
ici ou là notamment une question
d'actualité
la société la poste
n'est pas dépourvue de toute critique
d'ailleurs jean merci les deux
présidents et notamment le président
valent que j'ai reçue en début de
semaine que vous l'avez lu qui a
effectivement évoqué des améliorations
qui était possible y compris pour la
société la poste qui pourtant est plus
habituée si j'ose dire à la distribution
de propagande électorale puisque il y a
et des tableaux sont tout à fait à votre
disposition il ya pour ce qui concerne
la société la poste 9% depuis qu'ils
n'ont pas été distribuées ne sont pas
tous du mauvais travail fait par les 9%
des plis non distribués çà peut
correspondre aux personnes qui sont
décédées qu'on déménage et la spectra
qui est pas tenue mais la moyenne n'est
pas de 9% normalement et ne donnera
l'occasion sans doute d'en reparler nous
avons m7 pourcentage de non distribution
par département et par région que je
peux tout à fait souvenir de ce
président à votre commission en revanche
pour la société adrexo nous avons
constaté ce que vous avez pu montrer
monsieur le président qui n'était pas le
cas pour la société la poste des
documents qui étaient entreposés par
terre parfois mis dans des poubelles
parfois car exceptionnellement fin cas
quand même brûlé avec évidemment des
images qui ne sont remontés et qui ont
été évoquées par les par les réseaux
sociaux dans sa propre commune
la maire de la commune n'a pas reçu la
propagande électorale donc je suis bien
placé effectivement pour vous dire qu'en
effet et pourtant c'est la région de
france étaient concernés par ce site et
adrexo so far gone n'a pas été fait dans
les règles de l'art plusieurs raisons
ont été apportées par site et adrexo
vous les avoirs par vue médiatiquement
ils ont connu manifestement une attaque
informatique qui l'ont fait passer par
beaucoup de vacataires peut-être que ce
marché était finalement trop gros pour
eux mais chacun connaît aussi la société
adrexo et son professionnalisme
normalement la distribution de documents
c'est pas une société nouvelle
il faudra bien se poser ces questions
j'ai refusé pour l'instant de ce
président et je reviendrai aux solutions
de tirer toute conclusion son marché
public devant une société qui est
manifestement pris devant une difficulté
et l'important est de réussir le second
tour des élections et j'en tirais
personnellement des conséquences au
lendemain de ce second tour puisque
c'est le même marché qui organise
l'élection présidentielle et qu'il n'est
pas question d'avoir la même
me semble-t-il assurance même si avec
son présidentielle les choses seront
peut-être un peu plus simple puisqu'il
n'ya qu'une seule élection en même temps
ce jour là jusqu'à preuve du contraire
sur ces dates du mois d'avril que
désormais tout le monde connaît la la la
distribution du marché a été donc divisé
en grande région
je voudrais ici vous les citez auvergne
rhône-alpes c'était la société dans l'ex
au bourgogne franche comté avec sow
bretagne la poste centre val de loire
adrexo la corse la poste grand test
adrexo haute france adrexo ile de france
y compris paris la poste normandie
adrexo nouvelle aquitaine la poste
occitanie la poste outre mer la poste
pays de la loire adrexo provence alpes
côte d'azur la poste donc le marché a
été saucissonné ce jeudi rang 2 à parts
égales de population pour un montant à
peu près similaire de marchés publics
une fois que vous ai dit ça monsieur le
président dès les premiers
dysfonctionnements le secrétaire général
du ministère à ma demande a non
seulement contacter les prestataires
puis leur a écrit les courriels aux
dispositions puis les a convoqués pour
leur dire effectivement que ça ne l'a
n'allait pas du tout au lendemain de
l'élection du premier tour j'ai convoqué
moi même donc les deux sociétés en même
temps je leur demandais donc des
propositions d'amélioration notamment
dans la remontée d'information où les
gens n'avaient pas reçu leur propagande
depuis le lundi soir cela est mis en
place c'était un peu le cas ce n'est pas
le cas partout notamment en lien direct
avec bien sûr les préfets et les
sous-préfets
j'ai demandé aux sociétés d'écrire
directement au maire pour le signaler
j'ai demandé aux sociétés de mettre en
place des moyens de alternatif
distribution de la propagande lorsqu'il
a accédé pas à certains immeubles et de
rappeler évidemment aux sous traitants
leurs obligations
et effectivement à quatre jours
maintenant trois jours du second tour de
l'élection régionale et départementale
si nous pouvons améliorer un certain
nombre de choses dont on ne sait pas une
logistique pareil évidemment avec des
sociétés qui connaissent ces difficultés
dont nous tirons tout compte toute
conséquence ce qui est je terminerai par
là monsieur le monsieur le
le président ce qui est étonnant dans
notre système électoral c'est que nous
sommes un des seuls pays à fonctionner
encore avec ce type de propagande
électorale distribuer l ainsi depuis
longtemps le ministère de l'intérieur
et cela a été le cas de beaucoup de mes
prédécesseurs j'ai regardé les archives
ont proposé la démat alisation d'une
partie de la propagande au moins de ceux
qui ne souhaitaient pas la recevoir en
papier le législateur et thouars
exécutif l'a toujours refusé nous
constatons aussi que parmi les taux de
participation qui ont été très bas 87 %
chacun a vu ce chiffre des gens de moins
de 35 ans donc pas participer à
l'élection
alors qu' il est de coutume de penser
peut-être que c'est un a contrario qu un
peu trop facile mais que c'est plutôt
les personnes les plus âgées qui lisent
la propagande et personnes les plus
jeunes qui s'informent sur internet
donc on peut considérer aussi que la
question de l'abstention tient à un
effet de génération qui n'est pas tout à
fait lié à l'utilisation la propagande
mais je reste effectivement persuadé que
les chiffres de 1% qui a été donné par
société adrexo et 2 0% donnée par
société la poste ce qui a permis à ma
ministre délégué d'évoquer ce qu'avaient
dit les sociétés
ce n'est pas le chiffre que nous
retenons bien évidemment sinon je
n'aurais pas convoquer ses dirigeants
ils n'ont pas fait plusieurs alertes
devant devant à la fois l'opinion et
avant l'opinion qu'effectivement nous
avons un certain nombre de problèmes
distribution qui est bien largement
supérieurs à ceux % de la société avec
soi en tant que tel nous ne connaissons
pas encore exactement aujourd'hui le cas
c'est pas à nouveau
je prends les cas la société de la poste
qui lors du dernier scrutin n'a pas
distribuer l'intégralité des propagandes
électorales commune d'annecy et
représentant de ce département il pourra
en témoigner
il ya toujours eu des erreurs dans
l'inscription propagande électorale mais
à ce niveau de non distribution il est
évident que ce n'est pas le cas et que
nous devons particulièrement le regard
des près ce que j'allais vous dire
monsieur le président on a portant à
votre connaissance ces tableaux si vous
le souhaitez je demande également aux
sociétés de nous communiquer par écrit
quels ont été leurs difficultés j'ai
votre disposition d'ailleurs leur
courrier et j'ai évidemment les
courriers que je leur ai écrit ou co
secrétaire général du ministère chargé
des élections
leur a écrit bien en amont de la
convocation de cette commission est bien
avant du premier tour des élections
régionales et départementales
merci
ministre vous évoquez les erreurs que
nous avons connue avec nous en avons
connu dans les élections bien évidemment
peut-être pas de cette ampleur mais en
la circonstance quand une des images que
nous venons de voir
il s'agit de véritablement de faute
grave
compte tenu des attitudes des
comportements tels qu'ils ont été
constatés les choses sont de deux
natures me semble-t-il différentes très
accessoirement j'attire votre attention
sur le fait que notamment dans les
bouches-du-rhône à marseille en
particulier 34 bureaux de vote n'ont pas
ouvert
sur les 480 bureau certes c'est à
l'initiative des élus locaux est que
dépend cette organisation cela dit le
fond dans le cadre de leurs fonctions de
représentant de l'état sur ce point là
les préfets ou le préfère la
circonstance ont ils été averti et et
verront-ils naturellement à l'occasion
du prochain scrutin dans la bonne tenue
de ses bureaux de vote ce n'est ni son
oui merci monsieur président puisque
vous me prêtez de l'évoquer je voudrais
souligner en amont le très grand
professionnalisme des maires de france
et les anneaux préfecture qui ont tenu
un double scrutin dans des conditions
absolument exceptionnel et tous les
bureaux de france tous les bureaux de
vote de france entre maires ont ouvert
avec des bureaux qui sont conformes aux
recommandations du conseil continuez du
conseil d'état tout le monde tout ce
qu'ils ont pu l'être ont pu être
vaccinés
tous les autres tests étaient
disponibles et y compris dans les
inondations nous avons connu la veille
je pense à l'aise je pense dans
l'essonne les bureaux de vote étaient du
alors que parfois des litres mairie ont
été détruites ce que j'ai constaté moi
même hirson hier soir dans un
déplacement effectivement seule une
trentaine de bureaux de vote de la ville
de marseille n'ont pas ouvert à l'heure
34 exactement sur 481 bureaux de la
ville de marseille et le préfet a été
averti à 6h30 du matin le dimanche que
34 sacoche à dire ce que les présidents
de bureaux de vote chacun le connaît ici
évidemment mais je le dis pour ceux qui
nous écoutent n'avait pas été retiré
non pas du fait de la préfecture mais
évidemment en tout cas c'est ce que nous
constatons du fait de la ville de
marseille dont j'ai bien compris qu'elle
agissait au nom de l'état en tant
qu'agent de l'état puisque chacun sait
et je le répète souvent parfois ça et
objets de discordance avec un certain
d'entre vous que les maires sont à la
fois élus et agents de l'état
par ailleurs mais ce n'est pas à vous
que je vais la prendre et sur ses 34
présent de bureaux de vote 12 présidence
immédiatement été remplacé par des
agents de la préfecture de marseille que
je voudrais ici remercier qui ont été
réquisitionnés soit autorité du préfet
et d'autre on a pu être réouvert grâce à
l'action notamment de la ville qui a pu
convaincre ensemble de bureaux de vote
dont nous comprenons mais peut-être que
le préfet pourrait davantage compléter
mes propos dont nous comprenons que il
s'agissait d'un changement d'affectation
de tenir les bureaux de vote ici plutôt
qu'ailleurs
quand vous savez sans doute pour avoir
composé parfois les bureaux note que
certains élus sont très attachés aux
bureaux de vote où ils ont l'habitude de
présider et que ses habitudes n'ont
manifestement pas été totalement
respecté par ceux qui à l'époque ont
voulu désigner tel ou tel président du
renault dans tel ou tel bureau
voilà qui est la raison ils ont quand
même pu réouvrir même s'ils ont réouvert
effectivement avec du retard parfois
jusqu'à 12 heures 10 pour une partie de
ses bureaux c'est à dire une matinée
entière ce qui était bien tout à fait
déplorable
merci aussi mais je vais donner la
parole g8 demande de parole vraiment on
se tient aux deux minutes pour la
question je chronomètre je surveille
donc je ferai un peu la police de la
séance je vous prie de m'excuser par
avance monsieur jérôme durain et ensuite
monsieur le doyen waterblez monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président je tiens
d'abord à remercier le président du fait
d'avoir soutenu l'idée du président
caennais rld une commission d enquête
sur les faits qui nous réunissent
aujourd'hui et je veux témoigner des
grandes difficultés que nous avons
connues dans une région particulière la
région bourgogne franche comté où il est
évident que cette distribution très
aléatoire est très insuffisante de la
propre propagande électorale influer sur
le comportement électoral des citoyens
puis on a eu des remontées toute la
journée sur ce fait je m'étonne de la
mention à deux reprises par le ministre
du double scrutin comme si c'était une
quelque chose d'assez difficile
insurmontable si pour l'état 1 où le
scrutin est de nature à être une très
grande complexité faut pas organiser de
ce que tu en voilà ce soit on peut le
faire si on ne peut pas le faire je vais
aussi témoigner de ce qu'on entend dans
les préfectures du personnel préfectoral
qui parfois témoigne d'un sentiment de
honte parce qu'à la question de
l'élection elle même
et puis il ya quand même l'image de
l'état qui n'est pas capable d'assurer
le coeur ses missions alors quelques
questions très précises qui ici à
représente qui a reçu la propagande
électorale on est très nombreux à
l'avoir reçu
donc moi je ne comprends pas ce chiffre
des 21000 se mettre hors taxes des taxes
doivent être élevés en l'espèce parce
que dans beaucoup de nos départements
les chiffres sont immenses au niveau des
retours qu'on a lues deuxième question à
plusieurs reprises le ministre a mis sur
le même plan adrexo et la poste donc
j'aimerais qu'on ait des éléments très
documenté très qualifiés sur les retours
très surpris de cette mis sur le même
plan de deux sociétés qui n'ont pas les
mêmes retour visiblement et puis
dernière question un peu plus anodines
mais l'un des dirigeants d'adrexo
frédéric pons a déclaré quatre personnes
avaient impacté sa vie ses parents jeff
bezos c'est monsieur macron est ce que
vous savez pourquoi le site monsieur
macro est ce que c'est un rapport avec
les marchés qui ont été passés par
l'état
merci merci monsieur durand monsieur va
te plaît le président me l'intérieur
l'abstention était importante
c'est vrai mais on ne doit pas
dans ce cas-là mettre ça sur les
professions de foi en disant voilà il ya
eu un manque à gagner parce qu'il ya eu
vingt mille poissons non distribués mais
quand même ça fait un peu tache
parce que on part sur une élection
importante avec une telle partition et
surtout quand on voit ce pot de
participation on se dit qu'effectivement
il faudra rajouter mon la question est
différente elle pose d'abord sur les
critères de choix dans l'appel d'offres
des prestataires quels sont les critères
de choix pour la retenue des
prestataires et surtout quelles seront
les sanctions en fonction de ce qui se
passe parce que 200 millions ce qui est
un marché important c'est pas rien on
sait que la poste ou adrexo bon font
appel que forum en dynamite à des sous
traitants ou peut-être booster la
sentence d'ailleurs et peut-être des
gens qui sont appelés en renfort
peut-être pas fort mais il n'est pas
facile de faire un secteur distribution
on reconnaît et puis aussi et peut-être
on avait la poste avant qui était qu un
organisme
je veux dire leur public il y avait un
sérieux et est ce que la désolation de
la poste ne permet pas par année
justement à 7 dans des discussions parce
que quand on regarde la poste on se
rencontre que même pour décorer
classique on a des gros problèmes donc s
il ya pas de réorganisation est ce que
l'état doit pas reprendre en main
seulement cette mise sous pli cette
distribution face me supplier été bien
fait c'était dans les préfectures
mais cette dissolution est ce que la
pose de reprendre la main et refaire ça
ne font plus plus rationnelle merci
monsieur waterblez monsieur canard se
prépare avec luc hermann
oui mais monsieur le président monsieur
ministre on vient de vivre une situation
sans précédent dans notre république et
ses ministres ne pouvaient pas dire que
vous ne saviez pas zerg était interrogé
lors d'une question d'actualité sur les
dysfonctionnements déjà constatée sur
les petites entre guillemets élections
législatives partielles
donc on avait déjà des premiers éléments
qui montrait que peut-être nous allions
dans le mur et nous y sommes allés en
klaxonnant le mode fiasco est utilisée
par le président je le partage l'état a
failli l'état a failli dans cette dans
ce dossier il est vrai que les 32
millions de français qui n'ont pas les
beautés ne sont pas allés voter
uniquement pour cette question technique
mais ça n'a pas encouragé moi j'ai
rencontré dans les bureaux de vote que
je fréquente habituellement dans mon
canton
j'ai rencontré les personnes âgées qui
m'ont dit monsieur kader on n'a pas pu
préparer notre vote parce que d'habitude
elles préparent leur vote avec le
bulletin qu'elles reçoivent à l'occasion
des déplie sur les professions de foi
donc fiasco fiasco sur les régionales
mais fiasco aussi sur les
départementales
on a reçu et ça a été dit les documents
électoraux avant même l'ouverture de la
campagne officielle
alors qu'en principe les professions de
foi même si c'est ringard
vous l'avez quasiment dit monsieur le
ministre les professions de foi papier
c'est le dernier document qu'on reçoit à
deux ou trois jours avant l'échéance qui
permet de déterminer son choix réel donc
l'état et le donneur d'ordre vous êtes
le donneur d'ordres est donc la question
que je voudrais vous poser elle est
simple c'est tout d'abord est ce que
vous considérez que la sincérité du
scrutin est entaché ou au moins
partiellement entachée deuxièmement est
ce que vous considérez que vous avez
pris les bonnes mesures entre les
alertes des élections législatives et le
premier tour des élections
départementales et régionales pour
éviter justement les mêmes désagréments
qui se sont malheureusement produit et
troisièmement ministre c est vous n'avez
pas du tout évoqué mais je peux je peux
bien le comprendre
c est ce que vous estimez qu'il y a une
responsabilité du ministère de
l'intérieur dans ce dossier et donc
votre responsabilité personnelle bien
évidemment merci monsieur câlin malin
akerman 15,8 monsieur board
merci monsieur le ministre je crois que
ce n'est pas qu'un simple problème
d'adressage auxquels nous avons été
confrontés mais bel et bien en tout cas
à une distribution de fait manifeste
voire parfois même à une destruction de
ce qu'on appelle le matériel officiel
cela pose un véritable souci
dans l'organisation des missions cela
pose un véritable souci démocratique et
bien évidemment si la question n'est pas
de renvoyer cette situation pour
justifier uniquement l'abstention de
dimanche dernier force est de constater
que vous voyez quand il y à trois voix
d'écart entre des candidats et donc la
question de la qualification au deuxième
tour à une élection cantonale se pose on
peut tout de même s'interroger sur est
ce que oui ou non si le matériel avait
été envoyé dans les temps les résultats
utt les mêmes au vu des nombreux
témoignages que nous avons les uns et
les autres de gens qui effectivement ont
découvert ce son et est en difficulté
n'avait pas leurs habitudes et c'est une
élection c'est aussi toutes ses
habitudes
alors oui vous avez raison la
libéralisation du marché fait qu
aujourd'hui le groupe adrexo avec ses
17300 temps partiel de distributeurs
dont la spécialisation n'est pas la
distribution adressage c'est une
distribution toutes boîtes mais pas
forcément avec un adressage spécifique
pose aujourd'hui un réel souci dont il
est temps de tirer les enseignements
nous vous avions également fait un
certain nombre de remonter en amont
on peut donc regretter que dans les
quelques jours qui ont précédé il n'y a
pas eu plus de popularisation sur par
exemple ce site internet sur lequel il y
avait l'ensemble des professions de foi
qu'il n'y pas eu à des mesures prises
pour contourner cette difficulté
permettez moi mais le mais le mec des
préfectures un vendredi soir nous
demandant d'informer les électeurs de
regarder leur boîte aux lettres le
samedi après 18 heures parce que la
distribution continuerait est un peu mal
venu parce que si nous avions eu les
moyens de contacter tous les électeurs
en amont bien évidemment il n'y a plus
besoin de distribution de matériel
officiel
monsieur bah monsieur le ministre des
millions de français se déterminent chez
eux après avoir lui les professions de
foi ou confirment leur choix après les
avoir lus c'est dire que les
défaillances graves générale et sans
précédent qui ont été constatés ces
derniers jours ont nécessairement eu un
impact important sur le déroulement du
scrutin
nous ne sommes pas ici pour discuter des
causes multiples de l'abstention il
faudra le faire ce n'est pas le moment
nous sommes ici pour vous entendre
entendre vos explications sur ces
défaillances et je dois dire que les
explications que vous nous avez donné ne
m'ont pas convaincu lionel jospin a bon
dos et les directives européennes ont
bon dos ça fait 20 ans qu'elle
s'applique
deuxièmement contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit en 2008 il y a eu un scrutin
cantonal et un scrutin municipal en même
temps aucune difficulté de type de celle
que nous constatons cette année enfin
les inscriptions sur les listes
électorales
mais monsieur le ministre c'est vous qui
avez mis en oeuvre le nouveau système
d'inscription qui est justement destinée
à fiabiliser les inscriptions sur les
listes électorales
alors soyons sérieux quand il y à des
appels d'offres encore faut-il que les
cahiers des charges soient suffisamment
précis et la question que je veux vous
poser à les doubles en réalité à combien
évaluez-vous le nombre d'électeurs qui
n'ont pas reçu les professions de foi
vous avez dit tenir des documents à
notre disposition vous vous exprimez ici
en public je veux entendre ce nombre
deuxièmement si c'était à refaire
monsieur le ministre que feriez-vous
pour éviter ce fiasco
merci monsieur bas madame goulet puis
monsieur kerrouche madame boulet je ne
m'en reste encore de gaulle a disparu
mais j'étais rouge est prêt ainsi
monsieur kerrouche match et en asie
pardon oui vous dire que dans l'ordre
les choses se sont très mal passé en
matière de distribution que la possède
en revanche très bien réagi puisque elle
a mis les professions de foi sur le site
de la préfecture donc ça c'était c'était
formidable
mais moi je voudrais savoir deux choses
1 est ce que le ministère a été près de
prévenus de l'attak informatiques eux de
la société parce que c'est facile de
trouver un argument après mais ce que
vous avez été informé en temps réel de
cette panne informatique et deuxièmement
je rejoins ce qu'elle dit c'est thinker
mal qu'est ce qu'on va faire de la perte
de chance parce que déjà les gens
n'étaient pas très motivé pour aller
voter mais ce n'est pas le sujet de
l'audition d'aujourd'hui en revanche
nous avons aussi beaucoup de témoignages
de gens qui ne sont pas allés voter
simplement parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
reçu cette propagande quand les
candidats sont dans des situations de
proximité en raison des résultats du
premier tour moi je considère que la
question de la perte de chance va se
poser et éventuellement de
l'invalidation d'un certain nombre de
scrutins
quelle est votre opinion sur le sujet
merci monsieur le ministre mbola
monsieur kerrouche vieux monsieur
d'arnaud merci je couple à la vidéo pour
être bien entendu je ministre d'abord
une remarque vous avez continué à me
dire aujourd'hui que le vote par
correspondance n'était pas une solution
on aurait pu penser à un peu plus
d'humilité au vu de ce qui s'est passé
dimanche vous avez pris l'exemple de
l'angleterre c'est facile de prendre un
exemple qui ne fonctionne pas le
gouvernement le cas l'anglais n'a pas du
tout la même importance que le
gouvernement local français moi je peux
vous citer beaucoup d'exemples dans
lesquelles notamment en allemagne le
taux de participation est accrue à cause
du vote par correspondance
mais ce n'est pas le sujet mais le
ministre vous avez vous avez imposé
pendant j'ai fait partie du comité de
suivi des élections vous avez imposé des
td pratiquement impossible pour tenir
les délais ans qui maintenant ce qui
concerne les élections départementales
et donc assurer un séquençage des
élections dont je ne pense pas que le
problème soit le plein soit vraiment là
le problème de l'acheminement a été
soulignée de multiples fois pendant
l'ensemble de ces comités
à chaque fois l'adema nous a dit que
c'était relativement marginal donc la
question est toute simple
kan avait été vous alerter sur les
difficultés parce qu'elles sont remontés
assez vite et quelles mesures effectives
vous avez vous avez prise avant le
premier tour pour éviter cette situation
merci si monsieur queiros monsieur
garneau puis monsieur hervé après le
ministre aura la parole monsieur
d'arnaud oui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
moi je veux revenir sur la question de
l'anticipation vous
même vous l'avez souligné en précisant
que s'agissant singulièrement des
élections départementales nombreux sur
nos concitoyens qui ont reçu cette
propagande électorale de façon très
anticipé donc de la même manière il eût
été possible de redresser la barre quand
on a constaté qu'à certains endroits du
territoire cette propagande n'avait pas
été distribué d'ailleurs je veux revenir
sur les propositions nombreuses que nous
avons formulées depuis longtemps ici
même à la con à la commission des lois
convaincu que la situation particulière
issue de cette crise sanitaire pouvait
générer ce type de dysfonctionnement et
qu'à aucun moment on a eu le sentiment
ni même lors de la commission de suivi
qui devait permettre d'organiser au
mieux ces scrutins et dont les demandes
ont souvent été balayée d'un revers de
manche pense notamment à la question des
problématiques d'approvisionnement du
papier qui a donné lieu à des réponses
très tardive à la question de tout ce
qui concernait le matériel de propagande
monsieur kerrouche l'a souligné sur le
fait que cette cette fois-ci lille a
fallu notamment pour les élections
encore une fois départementale fournir
ce matériel de propagande pour les
candidats de façon très anticipée donc
comment se fait ce qu'aujourd'hui nous
n'ayons pas pu avec certains outils
parler de l'outil internet mais d'autres
moyens de propagande redresser la barre
dès lors que nous avons constatées et de
façon assez tôt le problème de
l'acheminement de cette propagande
électorale est ma deuxième question
c'est comment pouvons-nous encore
puisqu'il ya un deuxième tour eiffel
souligné redresser la barre avant
vendredi
parce qu'on entend ici et là que le
matériel de propagande pourrait même
être distribués ce week-end ce qui ne
manque pas de nous interpeller
parce que rare sous nos concitoyens qui
vont ouvrir et relevé leurs boîtes aux
lettres le samedi ou le dimanche matin
voilà je vous remercie monsieur si
monsieur d'arnaud monsieur le qu'hervé
qui est en visioconférence et merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
dans la droite ligne de ce qui a été dit
par mathieu darnaud à l'instant moi je
considère que l'exploit est à réaliser
devant nous puisque la propagande des
élections départementales ministre veut
également plus
moi celle des régionales est arrivé
quand elle est arrivée juste avant le
premier tour mais là vous avez
effectivement un exploit à réaliser un
exploit réalisé en cette fin de semaine
ça c'est nouveau une vraie difficulté
j'aimerais savoir de quelle manière vous
prévoyez cette distribution bon annecy
et été évoquée par le président par vous
même évidemment l'un département
extrêmement concernés c'est à ce titre
là aussi j'interviens et enfin ra sujet
très pratique qui est la question des
accès aux copropriétés c'est vrai qu'il
est aujourd'hui plus compliqué d'accéder
boîte aux lettres contre x pour ça qu'on
fait un peu de tractage militants ces
dernières années ils le savent
qu'est ce qu'on met complètement à loi
est en vigueur à cette distribution des
documents électoraux pour que autrefois
les facteurs ayant disposant d'un pass
postale pour accéder aux boîtes aux
lettres
comment est ce qu'on fait pour que cette
distribution puisse avoir lieu voilà je
vous remercie mme janice oui monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez dit que 9% des plis
acheminés par la poste était pas arrivé
quel est le pourcentage des plis dévolu
à adrexo qui ne sont pas arrivés
merci monsieur et pour terminer monsieur
alain richard le monsieur le président
très brièvement d'une part je dois
apporter une indication à la suite du
propos de certains collègues moi je
considère pour avoir assisté à toutes
ces réunions que la commission de suivi
qui a été mise en place par le ministère
de l'intérieur est présidé par jean
denis combrexelle a rempli très
correctement sa mission et que à chaque
fois qu'un sujet ne relevant pas de la
loi à ce sujet ne relevant pas de la loi
a été soulevé lors de ces réunions
hebdomadaires ou ou par mail puisque
elle fonctionner un peu aussi en
permanence
les meilleures réponses les meilleurs
diligence ont été apportées par les
services du ministère et le cabinet du
ministre étaient étaient représentés ou
à la question que j'ai posée au ministre
puisque nous sommes dans un état de
droit qui ne va pas changer
c'est à dire que la distribution de
courrier et maintenant une activité de
marché qui restera en situation de
concurrence sachant que cette opération
unique très contrainte ne présente que
très peu d'intérêt économique pour les
acteurs privés ce qui explique que alors
qu'il ya des centaines de millions
d'euros à gagner à recevoir en tout cas
il y a eu un seul candidat qui s'est
manifestée en dehors de la poste c'est
que peut-on mettre de plus dans le
cahier des charges pour éviter ou en
tout cas pour rendre sanctionnables les
manquements auquel il a été qu'ils ont
été relevés et puisque la question mi6 a
fait allusion la question s'est posée il
ya deux ans de savoir si on devait ou
non conserver le délai d'une semaine
entre les deux tours en particulier dans
ce cas d'élection double si il n'y a pas
à revoir la position que qui a été prise
par le gouvernement et qui a été suivie
d'ailleurs par le parlement et de
détendre l'écart entre les deux tours à
deux semaines merci merci monsieur
richard voilà monsieur le ministre
onze interventions autant de questions
je vous donne la parole tout de suite
merci monsieur merci monsieur président
les questions sont diverses j'essaie de
répondre à la suite des intervenants
s'ils veulent permettre de ce dur évoqué
les moyens de l'état je rappellerai des
effets tout à fait vérifié dans le
budget exécuté 2010 année d'élections
régionales 189 millions d'euros prévus
pour les élections 2015 961 millions
d'euros près vrai section 2021 328
millions d'euros prévus pour les
élections c'est à dire que le budget des
élections a plus que doublé en dix ans
pour organiser ces scrutins il me semble
pas sur une question de moyens de l'état
bien au contraire ils ont été
je mens au rendez vous j'évoquerai
d'ailleurs le fait que monsieur le
sénateur richert bien de le dire la la
commission combrexelle qu'on a mis en
place justement avec l'ensemble des
optiques dont certains d'entre vous sont
présents et il serait très heureux de la
commission denquête que ceux présents ce
qui permettra de fournir l'intégralité
des comptes rendus où on verra que cette
question a été peut voir à ma
connaissance pas abordé notamment par
les forces politiques les associations
d'élus où les élus qui y siégeaient dont
certains sont ici ce qui prouve qu
effectivement l'anticipation est assez
est assez difficile comme toujours mais
j'aurais salué le travail évidemment de
monsieur combrexelle comme vous l'avez
évoqué toi d'ailleurs souligné à votre
commission que la plupart des pays qui
nous entourent ont reporté leur élection
en 2021
l'italie la finlande l'autriche le chili
la croatie la pologne la serbie pour
parler que des pays qui avaient des
élections en 2021 qui sont démocratiques
et qui sont les plus proches d'entre
nous
vous évoquez pourquoi l'état n'est pas
capable de tenir ce qu'il a fixées serge
rappelé double scrutin je rappelle que
c'est le parlement qui a souhaité le
double scrutin
j'étais moi-même parlementaires à
l'époque nous avons été un certain
nombre à voter contre d'ailleurs
et puis je constate aussi que c'est le
parlement qui avec les associations
d'élus avec une grande partie des maires
de france a souhaité de tenir ces
élections qui ont été par deux fois
reporté et tout me permettrai de
souligner au sénateur kennedy cette
parcelle a été reporté trois fois
monsieur bah pardon de vous dire que
vous dit une bêtise 2008 n'a pas été une
année de double scrutin
elle a été une année de scrutin
municipal et pour la moitié des france
de scrutin cantonal pour la première
fois mais qui dit une bêtise monsieur le
ministre c'est bien vous monsieur le bas
si vous me le permettez d'ailleurs
personnellement vous parlez de sincérité
du scrutin et n'étant pas juriste comme
vous et n'ayant jamais eu d'élections
pour ma part annulé je ne sais pas vous
pensez que qu'elle était enceinte hérité
du scrutin pour telle ou telle
organisation de vote
mais en 2008 il ya bien eu d'une part la
moitié de la france qui est connue des
cantonales et les municipales pour la
première fois l'intégralité du pays
avait des cantonales est l'hôte
enfin des départementales pardon l autre
des régionales notamment pour
l'organisation du scrutin présidents de
bureaux vote tenu par les agents de la
préfecture isoloirs c'est plus facile de
le faire quand un département prête à
l'autre
que lorsque l'ensemble des départements
connaissent ce double scrutin
donc je le répète que depuis 1986 notre
pays n'a été organisée de double scrutin
c'est un défi logistique très importante
qui a été tenue et en partie par les
maires de france en très grande partie
par les maires de france le sujet
n'étant pas l'organisation autant du
scrutin quand il trébuche de la
propagande qui est bien l'objet
principal de notre me semble-t-il de
discussion et donc je le répète on
pourra le vérifier ce jeu c'est assez
aisé que lorsque la moitié du pays
n'organise pas un double scrutin c'est
plus facile d'organiser que quand le
pays aura un double scrutin
pardon de ce tas parents de cet apparent
bon sens je voudrais effectivement dire
au sénateur webb l'aide que sur les
critères de choix
ce sont des critères qui étaient à 40%
comme depuis l'appel d'offres existent
pour le l'offre technique et 60 % le
prix pourquoi parce que c'est le point
principal de l'évocation et c'est pas
très nouveau dans l'appel d'offres café
ministère de l'intérieur c'est à peu
près le cas de tous les appels d'offres
publics et singulièrement poursuite
élections la double difficulté qu'a
ministère de l'intérieur c'est d'une
part une position monopolistique de la
poste dans plusieurs rapports ont
d'ailleurs démontré que les prix qui
étaient faits par la poste dont je
rappelle ici que la privatisation de la
poste qui a été l'objet ont semble t'il
d'attac qu'on a eu au parlement sur
pourquoi adrexo pourquoi il ya un marché
public indépendamment de la directive
là aussi je les dis puisque monsieur n'a
évoqué que monsieur jospin avait bon dos
la privatisation de la poste a été fait
dans les années 2010 bon de prendre
société qui aujourd'hui à une difficulté
très fortes malgré son grand
professionnalisme c'est la chute du
courrier ça a été évoqué dans son modèle
économique
donc cherche évidemment à s'attendre
d'autres débouchés et le ministère de
l'intérieur je n'étais pas ministre à
l'époque je veux bien endosser toute la
responsabilité puisque monsieur cameron
appelle quasiment ma démission parce que
la propagande n'a pas été distribué j'en
assume toute la responsabilité
il n'y a aucun problème je suis le
ministre de l'intérieur en tout cas
monsieur kader permettez moi de penser
que ce scrutin s'est tenu dans des
conditions tout à fait acceptable et or
je constate
je constate bien sûr je constate par
ailleurs qu'il a été surtout reposé sur
les agents de la préfecture les agents
du service public et les agents des
communes qui ont de façon extrêmement
loyale à la volonté des initiateurs du
gouvernement
organiser un scrutin dans des conditions
sanitaires très complexe et chacun le
constate ici que n'ont pas fait les
autres pays
mais je veux dire aux sénateurs webleads
que la difficulté principale c'est que
nous avions un opérateur qui était la
poste qui comme il est et
monopolistiques faisait des prix qui
sans doute était pas très conforme me
semble-t-il au service que la puissance
publique
quels que soient les gouvernements ont
demandé et nous avons vu d'un bon oeil
mais collectivement depuis l'ouverture
la concurrence un deuxième acteur il y
en a malheureusement qu'un deuxième et
ce deuxième acteur qui a été validé dans
sa compétence par l'arcep a peut-être un
problème important c'est qu'il ya trop
de sous traitance c'est peut-être le
problème principal de notre situation me
semble-t-il
et d'ailleurs je ne devrais pas plus que
ça a chargé la société adrexo qui
pourtant est celle qui est l'objet des
images que vous avez auquel ce président
et dont je ne retiens pas les faux que
j'étais moi même l'occasion de dire que
c'était de rex au avait eu des
responsabilités très fort dans cette
société
dans cette difficulté mais elle a aussi
des personnes dont c'est le travail dans
ces métiers qui habite sans doute vos
communes votre département et qui sont
sans doute très touché par la mauvaise
publicité qu'on leur fait même si elle
est juste je ne le faisais si mahb solu
ment pas et qu'on en tire est ce des
conséquences demain ou après demain que
prévoit le marché prévoit évidemment que
si le marché n'est pas exécutée
conformément aux puisse revenir sur une
clause voilà et peut-être que ce sera la
conclusion qu'on en tire à tous
je ne veux pas le faire avant le second
tour des élections chacun le comprendra
et en attendant de voir les mesures de
redressement que price était vrai que
sow le présent sueur évoqué très
justement le 9 % de plis non distribués
pour la poste c'est le même montant de
plis non distribués pour la société
adrexo la seule difficulté c'est que
dans certains endroits la la la la
différence entre départements si je sens
cette moyenne 2,9 bien distribué mal
distribué beaucoup plus importante pour
rester dans l'axé pour la société la
poste si je prends un autre exemple la
société la poste quand elle distribue le
courrier et qu'on ne trouve pas les
personnes qui sont allocataires de ce
courrier dans l'immeuble dans lequel ils
vont notamment distribué ce courrier
elle reprend les plis ce qui
manifestement pas de la cadence et
adrexo qu'ils allaient laisser sur place
qui les a parfois mis dans des poubelles
qui les a parfois monsieur le président
a évoqué brûlé bon je le président
adresse aux a présenté ses excuses au
ministère de l'intérieur il a écrit mais
il est évident
que les taux que nous avons et nous
fournissons tous les tableaux parce que
le ministre d'intérieur a évidemment
suivi
cette distribution est le même montant
même si donc on se retrouve dans les
territoires urbains j'ai eu l'occasion
d'évoquer la lozère la seine saint denis
mais je peux prendre évidemment les
bouches-du-rhône les alpes-maritimes on
est quand même à 13 % de non
distribution
voilà donc se pose la question
effectivement à l'intérieur du ce
chiffre de 9 % de ceux présents sur les
différences qu'il ya et c'est différent
sont plus grandes pour la société adrexo
pour la société la poste nous avons bien
volontiers que effectivement la société
adrexo nous a fait savoir le 24 avril
qu'elle avait subi une attaque
informatique sans nous dire quelle est l
ampleur de cette attaque informatique ne
considérons pas que cette attaque
informatique par ailleurs a pu être la
seule responsable de ce que nous avons
vu je pense que si vous convoquez j'ai
compris que c'était votre choix
les deux sociétés vous expliqueront
davantage quel était l'objet de cette
attaque informatique et comment ils
l'ont résolu et commence à empêcher une
partie distribution de ceux de se coller
de propagande
monsieur le sénateur canadien évoque le
vote par correspondance est d'avoir
beaucoup d'humilité mais je ne comprends
pas la démonstration qui veut que si on
se pose la question de l'efficacité de
la distribution la propagande alors le
vote par correspondance sur la plus
efficace puisque par définition et les
voix il est voie postale
donc peut-être qu'il faut qu'on en
discute d'avoir la france est l'amie de
vote par correspondance jusqu'en 1975 et
c'est le législateur qui a souhaité la
nuit les pour des raisons qui tiennent à
la démocratie française ans quel âge
vous semble-t-il de plus respectable qui
est l'intimité du vote et la garantie
absolue du secret pour ne pas avoir de
commandes familial communautaire
patriarcale du vote donc en soi la
modernisation du vote et est un intérêt
pour douce je constate d'ailleurs que
peu de pays ont mis en place peu de pays
ont mis en place quelques grandes
démocraties c'est vrai les états unis
l'angleterre dont on peut pas regarder
les taux de participation comme étant
particulièrement plus fort que les
autres ils sont en général moins
important qu'un autre
à l'exception de l'allemagne qui a mis
en place le vote par correspondance
parfois de manière plus généralisée
parfois même un second tour totalement
par vote par correspondance mais je
pense que c'est là l'intérêt des
réflexions que nous pourrions tout
savoir comment on garantit à la fois une
plus grande facilité du vote tout en
garantissant absolument le secret de
l'isoloir
c'est quand même une question
intéressante je constate d'ailleurs que
ce sont les partis politiques qui font
des votes par
par correspondance beaucoup remettre en
cause les résultats lorsqu'ils ont perdu
ces élections à l'intérieur de cette
partie et je considère que les français
l'étranger qui ont parfois voter par
correspondance
une grande partie des votes ont été
annulés par le juge de l'élection
considérant qu'il n'était pas conforme
justement la sincérité du scrutin donc
je pense pas que la modalité de vote
soit la seule responsabilité de
l'abstention voilà le je pense que
évoqué simplement les modalités et qu'il
faut sans doute réfléchir moderniser et
améliorer le vote électronique imaginons
peut-être est tout à fait possible mais
ça ne sonne résoudra pas profondément le
sujet d'abstention 4ème plus politique
plus profond que la modalité gt1 der
attention des législateurs que l'inde si
justement
désormais nous empêche de renouveler les
communes qui ne font pas le vote par
core solo et électroniques
mais le vote électronique dans le bureau
de vote les machines à voter les
machines à voter nous parce que l'anssi
a considéré que les attaques
informatiques étaient trop nombreuses et
dans des communes très importante
le havre par exemple je regarde la
sénatrice qui m'a déjà saisies sur ce
point issy les moulineaux par exemple
selency mêmes notre gendarme
informatique qui nous empêche qui
souhaitent nous empêcher le
renouvellement de ces machines nous
avons trouvé une solution pour les
scrutins qui arrivent mais profondément
je pense que le dg d'ainsi serais très
heureux d'expliquer pourquoi il oblige
mista l'intérieur à ne pas renouveler ce
matériel où il ya des sociétés
d'ailleurs qui sont de moins en moins
nombreuses à proposer ce genre c'est
contre intuitif de de vote
donc pour répondre aux sénateurs qui est
intervenu je pense que le débat du de la
modalité de vote et du vote par
correspondance et est un débat qui se
pose évidemment mais ne me paraît pas si
évident que ça vu les enjeux à la fois
logistiques de sécurisation mais bien
évidemment aussi de vote dans l'intimité
de chacun en tout cas c'est ma
conviction profonde c'est déjà eu
l'occasion d'expliquer devant le devant
le parlement
un certain nombre d'autres questions ont
été ont été posées
jeu j'en ai oublié par dont la question
de la sénatrice luc hermann si elle veut
bien le programme là me l'a proposé je
considère personnellement que oui le
secrétariat général et demi ça
l'intérieur a suivi effectivement le
déroulement du scrutin dans des
conditions qui n'était pas facile parce
qu'il ya eu des reports d'élections mais
évidemment bien sûr qu'il a une part de
responsabilité en tant que responsable
du marché sans aucun doute je crois que
ses responsabilités ont été exercés je
pourrais fournir tout document à votre
commission ou à la commission denquête
si vous décidez effectivement de la cré
avec grand plaisir et nous constatons
que les explications proposées par les
sociétés ne sont jusqu'à présent pas
convaincu non plus monsieur président
bat pas convaincu non plus si demain le
parlement souhaitait que nous reprenions
en régie un certain nombre de choses
notamment pour assurer le service public
des élections moi personnellement je n'y
verrais pas d'inconvénient
acceptons alors de considérer que la
propagande électorale en lice aux
élections doit pas être soumis à la
concurrence
ce à quoi je crois le ministère de
l'intérieur serait assez heureux puisque
ça permettrait de remuscler évidemment
les préfectures sur la distribution du
week end jeudi au sénateur d'arnaud ça
me semble-t-il de toujours été le cas il
ya toujours une distribution de
propagande y compris le samedi après
midi
je n'ai pas l'expérience de chacun ici
mais ça fait quelques années quand même
que je me présente à des élections il
m'est arrivé de constater que mes
propres chansons est parfaite j'ai
trouvé ce samedi après midi
ce n'est pas etc mais ces mêmes ces
mêmes a regretté monsieur le sénateur
voit là est toute la question est dans
la réponse de monsieur richard si vous
permettez une semaine entre deux tours
cinq jours ouvrés alors qu'on dépose ses
documents de propagande vous savez bien
le lundi soir en préfecture le lundi
midi hôpitaux plus tard pour votre
imprimeur s'il est sympathique parfois
même les gens vous savez bien être la
profession de foi avant le premier tour
logistiquement parlant avoué que c'était
simple pour personne
d'ailleurs je constate que vous même
vous l'avez évoqué sur les les
propositions du sénat vous avez
plusieurs fois dit sur les imprimeurs
sur les routeurs sa distribution qui
avait un sujet de logistique
je crois qu'effectivement nous sommes
une des seules démocraties aussi en
avoir que cinq jours ouvrés entre deux
tours a d'abord ne sommes pas toute
démocratie à deux tours d'élections vous
le savez bien
et par ailleurs on accède jours ouvrés
entre les deux tours donc évidemment
cela pose un certain nombre de questions
logistiques le temps supplémentaire
serait sans doute un gage de meilleure
efficacité de distribution qu'est ce qui
a été mis en place pour la première fois
l'intégralité des professions de frais
de tous les candidats aux
départementales régionales est en mis en
ligne sur tous les sites de la
préfecture ils ont d'ailleurs été
extrêmement consulté pour la première
fois l'aï procuration a été mis en place
le fait de ne pas pouvoir se déplacer
contre cette opération 262000
procurations ont été mis en place pour
ce scrutin départemental et régional
quand on voit le taux de participation
on peut considérer que c'est quand même
plutôt une réussite à la fois
informatique et d'efficacité il reste
encore le moment où la personne doit
aller se présenter elle même devant
l'officier d'état civil l'officier
pardon de police judiciaire mais c'est
un débat éternel de savoir si on fait
confiance ou pas à la procuration être
on doit reconnaître ou pas cette
personne est ce que c'est la mairie qui
doit le faire est ce que c'est un agent
qui n'est pas un agent municipal
je ne vais pas revenir sur les quelques
sujets d'annulation des élections voire
d' enquêtes pénales qui existent sur la
situation des procurations
mais il faudra bien régler à la fin ce
problème de savoir si un quelqu'un de
neutre où doit voir physiquement cette
personne peut-être qu'on ait une
solution je dis au président de la
commission et à vous tous sur la carte
d'identité électronique que nous avons
mis en place en 1/4 d'identité
électronique parce qu'elle a une puce
parce qu'elle ressemble vous l'avez vu
une sorte de permis de conduire de carte
bleue permet sans doute de lutter bien
plus contre les usurpations d'identité
et peut-être que demain avec un terminal
qui vous est propre
peut-être un terminal même on peut
imaginer un terminal dans les services
publics sans avoir d'agent y compris de
façon de cure-dents les gars on peut
tout imaginer qu'on puisse identifier
numériquement la personne mais ça pose
un triple problème
qu'est ce qu'on met dans cette cadence
et électroniques dans le débat qu'on a
eues ici
il rassemble et il ya beaucoup de gens
qui souhaitaient avoir juste une pièce
d'identité et pas d'autres l'information
qui vous concerne et pour des raisons
propres à la cnil évidemment est propre
un verger pds qu'on accepte l'identité
numérique est un sujet absolument
passionnant mais qui pose des tas de
problèmes
évidemment
de libertés publiques comme en estonie
par exemple est-ce qu'on accepte ce que
ce soit que ça vaut l'identification
d'une personne mais tant que vous
n'aurez pas réglé la question de savoir
comment on vérifie nantis une personne
sauf à la voir physiquement on sera
toujours buté sur un certain nombre de
problèmes même sur les a largement
simplifié j'en terminerai par dire
monsieur le monsieur le président que et
pour répondre aux questions en excusant
par ailleurs si je ne suis pas le plus
convaincant pour le second tour encore
une fois je crois qu'elle sociétés font
aujourd'hui le maximum et singulièrement
la société adrexo qui est la plus
concernée pour améliorer la distribution
de la propagande il est évident que il
n'y aura pas 100% distribution de
propagande pour dimanche prochain en
trois jours je ce serait absurde de le
promettre mais qui est une amélioration
absolument générale que par ailleurs on
puisse mettre à disposition des
propagandes pour ceux qui ne les ont pas
reçu puisqu'un certain nombre de
dispositions sont prises concrètement
dans les territoires les plus touchés
notamment les territoires les plus
urbains et complice faire connaître
davantage que toutes les professions de
foi sont mis en ligne sur tous les sites
des préfectures et sous-préfectures de
tous les candidats même si évidemment ça
ne vaut pas le papier que vous évoquez
c'est tout le travail que fait le
ministère de l'intérieur en reprenant si
j'ose dire la main sur des marchés dont
je rappelle qu'il relève de plus de 200
millions d'euros et dont nous sommes en
droit me semble utile de demander à
l'associer aux sociétés concernées
qu'elles les accomplissent il nous en
tirons donc toutes les conséquences ne
les a compris ce pas monsieur le
ministre un plan pour rappeler que la
question d'un pic herman relevait
principalement des conditions d'emploi
des prestataires des personnes qui
travaillent pour le compte de la société
que l'on a évoqué tout à l'heure et
notamment des conditions d'emploi très
précaire de fait et en conséquence de la
compétence des personnes pour assurer la
qualité de la distribution
monsieur et monsieur bart voulait
reprendre la parole et puis ensuite vous
la redonne et puis ensuite on lèvera à
l'audition oui monsieur le ministre vous
avez été tellement occupés à contester
le fait qu'il y ait eu en 2008 des
élections cantonales et des élections
municipales que vous en avez oublié de
répondre à mes questions je voulais
répète à combien évaluez-vous le nombre
d'électeurs qui n'ont pas reçu les
professions de foi et deuxièmement si
c'était à refaire que feriez-vous pour
éviter ce genre de sinistres
démocratique et seul ministre
il me semble un peu madame plus kerman
elle a raison de dire qu'il ya beaucoup
de sous traitance et adrexo et parmi
cette sous traitance
c'est essentiellement soit des
vacataires soit des intérimaires soit
des agents d'insertion pour ceux qui
connaissent la société adrexo qui
distribuent parfois des documents qui
sont électoraux municipaux parce que
beaucoup de communes je les constate et
ailleurs ont des appels d'offres acte
c'était adrexo ce qu'ils vont sans doute
la confiance que cette société parfois a
pu respirer à tel ou tel à tel ou tel
élu il ya effectivement des clauses
d'insertion et peut-être que moi je
n'aurais pas juger le travail
d'insertion chacun sait que c'est un bon
mode de travail qui demande plus
d'encadrement et que c'est pas facile de
distribuer le courrier
c'est un métier que c'est un métier très
difficile et que effectivement peut-être
que c'était quelque chose de
sous-estimer et et que voilà la société
recto pourra fournir évidemment
l'intégralité de sa composition de force
du travail comme comme dirait l'autre
pour le bon monsieur bah jugement
saveurs et produits monsieur bah en tout
cas sur le premier point puisque j'ai
évoqué avec le président sur que des
deux côtés des deux sociétés 7 9% de
flynn ont distribué si on part du
principe c'est le taux général du
ministère de l'intérieur quel que soit
les élections même si on peut imaginer
que ça évolue un peu vu la mobilité des
personnes que 69% la moitié sonné un
taux résiduel des gens qui ont déménagé
dans l'année les gens qui n'ont pas fait
leur déclaration de changement parce que
parmi l'une des difficultés il n'y a pas
d'obligation de déclarer son changement
d adresse électorale contrairement son
changement de reste court c'est à dire
peut-être un des problèmes de notre
droit électoral
aussi si on part du principe des gens
qui sont décédés sur par des gens qu'ils
refusent le courrier qui font une pme
même parce qu'ils sont en marge de la
société par exemple soit par le gens qui
n'ont pas de boîte aux lettres c'est le
cas notamment le savez bien aux
territoires ultramarins on prend ça
tombe de territoires comme la guyane par
exemple c'est à peu près la moitié
cateau résiduelles donc il y a
on peut considérer entre 4 à 5% moi
c'est ce que nous constatons de gens qui
auraient dû recevoir cette propagande
électorale d'après les chiffres qui ont
été déclarées par les sociétés les
sociétés nous ont déclaré toutes les
deux qui avait 9 % de clients distribuer
la moitié c'est normal l'autre moitié
manifestement dépens de difficultés des
sociétés
après il y at il des gens qui n'ont pas
fait remonter ces informations avec les
sociétés d'un chiffre trop minorée je
pense que c'est ce que nous devons
regarder en tout cas ce que nous
regardons ministère de l'intérieur
qu'aurait-il a changé je vais vous dire
monsieur le président bah je ne crois
pas qu'il y ait grand chose a changé
quand je suis devenu en responsabilité
comme mon prédécesseur l'été puisque la
difficulté principale
monsieur le sénateur bas c'est le
principe de la mise en concurrence par
appel d'offres avec une société qui
manifestement n'était pas à la hauteur
du marché qu'on lui a proposé
donc c'est pour ça que je vous ai
proposé je vous ai fait une solution
tête on n'avait pas entendu c'est que je
suis d'accord moi pour que nous
puissions législativement considérer que
la propagande électorale ne doit pas
relever du domaine concurrentiel et que
nous puissions considérer que soit c'est
une régie ça n'a finalement pas été
jamais puisque la poste qui était une
entreprise publique entièrement travail
est toujours prête à ça pas été les âges
aux préfectures il ya 40 ans qui serait
mêlé plie mais la poste était le service
public si vous me permettez cette
expression
donc je serais favorable à ce que nous
puissions convient de considérer qu'il
n'ya pas de concurrence à voir dans la
distribution de la propagande électorale
et vous y avez vu une attaque pour
premier ministre jospin s'en était pas
une
je considérais simplement qu'on aurait
pu imaginer qu'en dehors de la directive
service postal
on aurait pu sortir la propagande
électorale d'ailleurs il ya eu des
débats vous le savez bien en ce moment
donc je pense que si le droit et est
ainsi écrit notamment législativement
cela serait tout à fait conforme us
intérieur et pourrait ainsi je veux bien
répondre évidemment toutes vos questions
je porte tous les péchés qu'on veut bien
me faire porter avouer que je ne dirige
pas les sociétés évoqué même si
évidemment nous sommes ceux qui avons
écrit le marché deuxième sujet monsieur
le président bah je crois qu'il faudrait
qu'on accepte l'idée que ceux qui ne
veulent pas recevoir la propagande
électorale comme les gens mettent stop
pub
devant leur boîte aux lettres puisque de
recevoir de manière électronique s'ils
le veulent et qu'on regarde un acteur
exemplaire papier
s'ils ne le veulent pas et recevoir
directement je pense que ça allégera la
fois les coûts et l'efficacité notamment
le fait que vous recevez quand vous avez
cinq personnes qui votent dans votre
maison
5 plis électoraux multiplié par deux
quand il ya deux tours de scrutin
avouez que chacun se pose des questions
écologiques bilan carbone quand il et
quand il les reçoit pour imaginer alors
qu'elle est différente dans les familles
chacun de le recevoir de lire ces
documents à les garder parce qu il les
collectionne parce que ça les intéresse
vous devez le comprendre on pourrait
imaginer comment la famille disent moi
je préfère recevoir des documents pour
la famille et pas que pour moi
troisièmement monsieur le sénateur bah
moi je considère personnellement qu'il
faudrait que la loi met une date comme
il ya des dates et des heures de dépôt
de listes en préfecture le code
électoral a prévu qui est l'horaire de
dépôt de liste à la préfecture
ce qui fait que je ne peux pas même si
j'essaye d'être extrêmement sympathique
avec tel ou tel candidat de la majorité
de l'opposition
si quelqu'un dépose à 18h02 sa structure
la loi m'interdit de l'ordre de leur
donner raison
bon donc je pense qu'il faudrait des
dates la distribution pour telle ou
telle élection sinon ben c'est une
semaine avant 15 jours avant qu'il
faudrait ont décidé de savoir quel
meilleur moyen pour la participation
afin peut-être d'assurer un moment de
rattrapage par la société ou par l'état
si jamais on n'est pas reçue la
propagande premièrement cette date
n'existe pas donc on ne peut pas
l'imposer aux missionnaires du marché
deuxièmement il me semble qu'il faudrait
que nous réfléchissions tous autant
entre deux tours de scrutin ce qui
permettrait d'être plus efficaces y
compris toi tu y avait des ratés
troisièmement je crois que ce qui ce qui
serait le plus ce qui serait le plus
efficace
bien évidemment ce serait de pouvoir
considérer que lorsqu on distribue la
propagande électorale on puisse la
mettre à disposition aussi des électeurs
y compris le jour du vote les documents
seuls officiels qui sont ceux que comme
vous l'a dit monsieur le call center
kaner le bulletin de vote dans la poche
pour les personnes qui ont vu leur garde
et occuperait le consulter après tout on
consulte bien les affiches dont certains
me mettre à sa tombe de texte s'il le
souhaite le savez bien
à l'entrée du bureau de vote pourquoi ne
ferions pas à trouver les professions de
foi pour s'isoler pour les regarder si
on n'avait pas la possibilité de voir
chacun pourra les voir électroniquement
pour les verts en papier dans chacun des
bureaux note donc des propositions il y
en a je ne suis pas certain monsieur le
président est
tout à fait prêt à y répondre puisque je
suis intéressé à cette question dès ma
nomination que nous aurions pu changer
grand chose vu les décisions dictées par
les mesures sanitaires et dont chacun se
rappelle à l'époque la grande question
qui se posait pour la tenue de ces
scrutins
et donc j'ai rappelé que beaucoup de nos
pays voisins avaient remporté ces
élections je suis pas certain que nous
aurions pu faire absolument mieux avec
les impositions de marché et les règles
sanitaires qui nous était imposé
merci monsieur les deux dernières
questions très très courte monsieur est
une minute une minute
merci le président et son ministre et
cher que la gaz sera extrêmement courte
je crois que le sujet qui nous rassemble
ce matin c'est de se dire que
effectivement en cas de défaillance dans
l'exécution d'une prestation
il ya deux façons de voir les choses il
ya la partie qu'avec évoqué notre
collègue julie bass et se dire est ce
que le cahier des charges était assez
précis mais il ya aussi une autre
obligation c'est celle des entreprises
qui s'engagent dans le marché public et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on peut toujours
dire que c'est la faute de l'état mais
je crois que les entreprises qui
s'engagent
ne serait ce que par équité pour les
entreprises qui ont été déboutés lors du
marché je pense que c'est valable aussi
dans les marchés publics dans les
travaux publics etc
quand on obtient un marché ne serait ce
que par par décence par rapport aux
entreprises qui n'ont pas de marché il
faut être en mesure de pouvoir réaliser
la prestation demandée
donc quand bien même le marché est
obtenu je pense qu'à une conscience
professionnelle aussi qu'il faut avoir
donc aujourd'hui on peut dire que c'est
la faute du gouvernement ou du de l'état
mais je dis que obtenir un marché est
une chose mais être en mesure de
l'honorer de l'honneur et en est une
autre
si même lherbier une minute j'aurais
voulu vous poser une question concernant
la production de documents at-on un
retour sur les difficultés des
entreprises à produire les documents
on a tous été candidat un jour ou
l'autre on a toujours eu des problèmes
avec les imprimeries qui étaient
vraiment tous dans des timing très serré
pour produire les documents
est-ce que vous avez des retours sur des
problèmes concernant justement les
lourdes commander d'autant qu'ils savent
être entre les deux tours il y aura très
peu de temps pour être produire ces
documents à l'armée je donne la parole
au ministre qui ensuite quittera la
séance mais je demande au commissaire de
rester doivent encore deux points à
l'ordre du jour a évoqué ses ministres
ainsi lâché le président bon je reviens
pas sur le l'évocation précédent de ce
sénateur
j'étais à la tension une nouvelle fois
se fait qu'il n'y a que deux sociétés
qui peuvent répondre par l'arcep à
l'appel
nous sommes soumis à concurrence de par
définition est l'un des deux qui gagne
mais ce que je veux dire
et les deux gagne forcément puisqu'on
doit à le tire lait l'eau donc en fait
vous êtes condamnés à donner à ces deux
sociétés dont les deux sont validées par
une autorité administrative indépendante
qu'est l'arcep la distribution donc pour
répondre à la question que vous ne posez
pas de la responsabilité du marché ce
qui ne veut pas dire qu'on va pas
remettre en cause comme celle de
monsieur bah par nature je suis obligé
en tant que chef d'administration
puisque monsieur kader m'invite à mes
responsabilités a constaté qu'il faut
faire une concurrence qui est imposé par
la loi
aida le tire forcément des marchés donc
il n'y a que deux sociétés qui peuvent
répondre et dont on peut donner co2 le
marché sont par définition le choix est
assez limité et si j'en suis aujourd'hui
à dire ni la poste ni avec son dos
travailler alors je peux pas distribuer
la propagande électorale l'entreprise
intérieur ce sera le cas de tous les
intérieurs de tous les gouvernements de
la république sauf à changer les règles
imprévu pas par la loi
donc évidemment ça n'empêche pas qu'il
ya des clauses qui permettent de ne pas
payer totalement la société de le
rappeler à des obligations de leur faire
une mauvaise publicité
avouez que ce n'est pas très positif
pour ces sociétés une fois qu'on a dit
ça à la fin des phases si on travaille
pas une des deux il y aura une partie
des propagandes qui sera pas distribuée
et ça pose quand même un sujet très
important
nous préparons dès maintenant l'élection
présidentielle j'oserais dire d'ailleurs
que lorsque le parlement le président à
cliquer souhaite un référendum et une
date
je prends par exemple la fin donne
nouvelle calédonie qui est aussi un défi
logistique extrêmement important
évidemment le sénateur il travaille
depuis des années et ces crédits comme
les organisations ne sont pas faits
quelques semaines quelques jours chacun
sans doute d'un scrutin donc je
comprends ce que vous dites monsieur de
sénateur je suis bloquée par une
concurrence qui n'en est pas une puisque
il y avait deux sociétés qui ont été
validés les deux doivent gagner x voilà
le problème que le miz d'intérieur a
aujourd'hui pour répondre à madame derby
et monsieur arnaud l'a évoqué bien sûr
comme à chaque fois il ya des tensions
elles ont été résolus à ce scrutin je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait un candidat qui
puisse dire qu'il n'a pas pu avoir accès
à son imprimeur à son papier mais il ya
trois problèmes le premier c'est la
qualité particulière du papier qui est
édicté de façon réglementaire depuis
longtemps un papier d'un certains
grammages appelé d'une certaine écologie
ce qui fait qu'à un moment donné que les
candidats s'y prennent au dernier moment
et c'est leur choix plus strictes
puisqu'ils ont pas se présenter au
dernier moment la vérité c'est qu'à
dépendamment des documents de propagande
électorale
il y a
des documents en grand nombre à double
scrutin c'est encore pire c'est de se
dire qu'il avait de produits avec un
nombre d'inscrits qui ont tendance à
descendre en nombre puisque vous savez
bien qu'il ya de moins en moins de
papier est par définition il ya de moins
en moins d'imprimerie et que par
ailleurs beaucoup de candidats veulent
et c'est bien produire enfin imprimés en
france
bah oui mais de fêter que quand il
apprit d'enfance effectivement il ya un
assaut des commandes par exemple que
chacun d'eux c'est donc à chaque fois
c'est tordu et c'est tendu notamment par
les délais qu'impose le code électoral
aux candidats et notamment entre les
deux tours premièrement deuxième sujet
la difficulté que nous avons c'est
effectivement aussi celui du routage
celui du routage il est d'autant plus
compliquée lorsque si je prends
l'exemple du second tour notamment
encore une fois comment ça se passe
normalement dans la vie des candidats
des cantonales et des départementales et
des régionales ils ont dû dans leur
société de communication voire
d'imprimerie direct validé pour midi
lundi lors documents électoraux pour
d'être imprimé dans la soirée de lundi
soir à portée dans les lieux désignés
par les préfectures et sous-préfectures
le mardi matin
mis sous pli de scrutin route et est
envoyé directement aux électeurs c'est à
dire que les sociétés ont quand même
grosso modo 48 heures pour distribuer
l'équivalent d'une journée entière de
courrier comme si chaque français relève
de l'être le même jour ça n'arrive pas
tous les jours qu'on viendrait troisième
sujet il ya eu pendant les crises du coc
vide et ça vous voyez avec aux
entrepreneurs localement une crise
générale de matières premières dont le
papier dont l'anc et donc c'est rajouter
à la difficulté habituel des délais et
du papier déjà la difficulté de recevoir
ce papier dans la plupart n'est quand
même pas produit en france sa filière
bois je ne vais pas la face la honte de
le rappeler évidemment pas tort qu'il
s'intéresse depuis longtemps à ce sujet
est compliqué en france et ce papier
souvent est exportée est enfin à portée
en france dans le cadre évidemment de la
crise que vides et à une paire d'une
pénurie de papier et d'encre mais
cependant à ma connaissance madame la
sénatrice
il n'y a pas eu ce genre de difficultés
mais cela a été filmé entendu ça crée
également je vous rappelle tensions sur
les prix dont l'état a fixé deux parties
en partie réglementaire les montants de
remboursement ce qui ne correspond pas
toujours il faut bien l'avouer
pratiqué par les imprimeurs donc une
sorte par ailleurs de concurrence qui
est parfois un petit peu malsaine il
faut bien faut bien l'avouer il n'y a
pas de monopole vous le savez bien pour
l'imprimerie je terminerais monsieur
président par dire j'ai aussi beaucoup
de remonter les sénateurs sueur on a dû
donner les résultats des départementales
dans les mairies à la sous préfecture et
des régionales à la préfecture
il ya parfois eu des différences entre
20 et 30 km entre les deux je rappelle
aussi que c'est législatif et que le
gouvernement souhaitait revenir sur ça
en donnant tout à la préfecture mais à
la demande de l'adf et une partie du
sénat nous avons accepté l'idée que l'on
puisse donner au chef lieu de canton
les résultats du canton et au chef lieu
de région
en tout cas de la préfecture de
département les résultats d'analysé
départementales régionales tout ça
allait très bien jusqu'au jour où on
organise le double scrutin
puisqu'on n'a pas changé la disposition
donc nous on a gardé évidemment l'idée
que le chef canton reste lieu qu on
centralise résultats du canton notamment
les listes électorales notamment les
résultats et au chef lieu de département
la question régionale faudra-t-il adapté
sans vexer les chefs de canton je ne
sais pas ayant été maire d'une ville est
chef-lieu de canton très heureux de
recevoir les résultats centralisés
mais il faut avouer que dans les
départements qui ne sont pas urbaniser
comme peut l'être ma commune
les gens n'ont pas toujours compris dans
les communes rurales pourquoi on faisait
30 km de la côte et des résultats et 45e
et de l'autre côté merci monsieur le
ministre on me signaler que madame
goulet n'avait pas eu sa réponse sur la
perte de chance je pense qu'ils étudient
le petit peut-être dit randy égard au
fait qu effectivement compte tenu du
volume de propagande qui n'a pas
distingué y at il une perte de chance
pour un certain nombre de candidats
alors le cnet le président combrexelle
comme les anémies ses intérieures
montrent que à notre avis il n'y a pas
d'alternative il n'y a pas de
difficultés pour la sincérité du scrutin
d'altération d'ailleurs il ya plusieurs
plus en jurisprudence
il ya plusieurs grands il ya plusieurs
jours de présence du conseil d'état qui
évoque des distributions non distribués
du tout des communes qui par l'europe je
rappelais commune d'annecy par exemple
qu'il avait eu aucune propagande et le
conseil d'état a toujours considéré
qu'il ne s'agissait pas de difficultés
profondes de sincérité du scrutin
merci monsieur le ministre pour votre
présence ce matin de nombreuses
questions et nous allons
continue naturellement de travailler au
sénat sur ce point particulier que nous
venons de vivre ces difficultés merci à
vous devant le commissaire de rester
simplement quelques instants